“I have an announcement to make
about wrongdoing at Waystar Royco.”
The Season Two finale of Succession
ends with Brian Cox’s titan of
industry, Logan Roy, cracking a
small, barely perceptible smile.
It’s a smile that might seem odd
given that he’s watching his son,
Kendall, publicly throw him under
the bus on TV and expose his
culpability for the cruises scandal
that could cause him to be ousted
as CEO from the company he built.
“I have with me today
copies of records
that show his personal sign-off…”
But I think this is the
day his reign ends.”
So why does Logan look, on some level,
a little bit happy about this?
This video is brought
to you guys by Mubi.
We love Mubi so genuinely,
it is a key part of our lives.
Mubi is such an
incredible platform—
it has wonderful movies and interesting
conversations around those movies.
Mubi always picks something that’s
interesting, that’s quality.
I crave that curation today.
You feel like you’ve actually
taken in something substantial,
and then you think about it,
you dream about it.
It stays in your head.
They have great taste.
It’s something for everybody.
If you want to know about
the world and culture and
what’s really fun and worth
watching, check out Mubi.
Right now Mubi is offering
our viewers 30 days free,
just click the link in the description
below to start streaming now.
In the Season Two finale when Logan
tells Kendall he’s making his son
the “blood sacrifice” for the cruise
scandal plaguing Waystar Royco,
this scene contains three key moments
of dialogue that basically tell us
everything about who Logan is, as
a businessman and as a father.
One involves the Roy family
belief that, in order to
make it in business, you
have to have killer instinct.
“Did you ever think I could do it?”
“The top job?”
“You’re not a killer.
You have to be a killer.”
Rewatching Seasons One and Two,
we’ll actually notice that
we were told all along that
Kendall’s lack of killer instinct
was why his dad doubted him—-
from the first episode when
Logan tells Kendall he “bent” for the
Vice-like media company named Vaulter.
“I hear you let the
guy from the website
trash talk you, and
you just let him come.”
“I hear it played weak”
to Shiv’s line in the second episode
“You lack killer instinct”
“I don’t think all that, I’m
just trying to be dad’s voice.”
to the two plots in Season One
when Logan berates his son
for coming for him and losing
“You lost, son.”
Logan’s view of business
is that it’s a battle.
“What the f[BLEEP]’s going’s on?
He’s selling me things I
want at a fair price?”
“He’s smiling.”
“It’s no good if he’s smiling.”
When Roman half-heartedly
tries to suggest that there’s
such a thing as a win-win,
“Objectively, I mean, if we get what
we want and he gets what he wants”
Logan counters that there’s no
success without hurt and killing:
“You screw them out and
then you watch them squeal.”
“I like hurting human beings
as much as the next guy.”
The very first episode of Succession
is entitled “celebration”
--as the family plans to celebrate
both tycoon Logan Roy’s birthday
and the planned announcement
that Kendall will replace
his father as CEO--
but really the whole birthday party
is a test, one which Kendall fails
by choosing to put family first.
“You left the room. The deal.”
“To come to my dad’s
f[BLEEP]ing birthday party!”
After Logan announces that he’s not
going to pass power on to Kendall
after all, he reveals that he
thinks Kendall is too soft to be CEO.
“Sometimes, it IS a
big dick competition.”
Kendall comes to understand that,
if he really wants the top job,
he’ll have to kill his father
(in a business sense).
“The only way he’ll respect you
is if you try to destroy him,
because in your position that is
exactly what he would try to do.”
“I can’t do that.”
“Well obviously,
so have fun in Shanghai.”
But whenever Kendall mounts an
attempt on his father’s business life,
he self-sabotages at the last-minute,
seemingly proving his father right
that he just can’t
summon the will to kill.
“Only 15 percent of men
when it comes to it
actually shoot an
undefended enemy soldier.”
Mid-way through the season, Kendall
plots a vote of no confidence,
but makes the incredibly
bad decision to fly out to
Long Island to convince Ilona,
(a vote he actually doesn’t need),
thus missing the vote and letting
his father muscle him out of the win
by refusing to leave the room
and bullying yes’s into reversing
their vote or abstaining.
At the end of Season One,
Kendall decides again to
kill his father--this time
through a hostile takeover
with his private equity buddy Stewie
and his father’s enemy Sandy Furness.
“It’s good to demonize
the enemy before a fight—”
“Yeah, yeah, yeah.”
“It’s good to demonize him
before you have to kill his ass.”
In the Season One finale, we hear
a callback to the first episode.
“It’s a celebf[BLEEP]ingbration--
you did it man.”
But again, just as Kendall’s
on the verge of actually getting
what he wants, he panics and
tells Frank about the plan
(even though Stewie
warned him not to),
thus spurring a leak which means
the bear hug has to be accelerated
and Kendall has to confront his
dad face to face at the wedding.
“you’re very tough and so am I..
I’m-I’m not sorry for what I’m doing,
but I’m sorry for how
it makes you feel.”
Kendall spirals out,
going on a bender,
“Yo, uh, do you have any more…”
“We got a huge day tomorrow.”
driving intoxicated, and causing
the death of a young caterer.
So at this point, rather than killing
his father, it seems that what Kendall
really wants is to revert to being
that helpless dependent child,
to be “rescued” by his
powerful dad’s safe arms.
“You’re my boy. You’re
my number 1 boy.”
“I’m sorry.”
“No no no.”
Season Two follows “broken” Kendall
who’s so determined to serve his dad
loyally that he’s
behaving like a robot,
“Look at you scanning for
influence like a yuppie robocop.”
who’d consider even a
thought independent of
his father as disobedient.
“You have a hard time finding
a happy medium between
worshipping him and
wanting to kill him.”
But while at first doing exactly
what his dad wants does seem to bring
the two closer together than ever,
it ultimately leads to his father
exploiting him at the
expense of Kendall’s health,
and planning to sacrifice him.
So all this explains why, in
that final moment of Season Two--
as a father, Logan is happy that
Kendall revealed he is a killer
. . . something Roman and Shiv
have not yet proved themselves to be.
“You better be smelling your
f[BLEEP]ing armpit, Romulus.”
“It's the sort of tough choice
people need to be able to make.”
“I can’t choose, dad”
“No.”
Of course, Logan the CEO and
business titan is still gonna
fight tooth and nail against
his son in Season Three,
but this is the look of a father
who is proud of his son
for proving a worthy adversary.
A second key moment in the father-son
scene is where Kendall reveals why
he’s willing to accept
this public punishment.
“I deserve it.”
“Oh no son--”
“Yeah. For everything.”
“No, no, no, God no.”
“The boy.”
“Nah nah nah Not that.”
His father makes it clear he
literally doesn’t care about
or believe in any of that moralizing.
But what Logan has done to his son,
which is both genius and evil,
is to weaponize the boy’s better self--
the human being who feels and
cares about things--against him
“Are you gonna f[BLEEP]ing cry?”
to make Kendall view that self
(and his emotions in general)
as weakness, and to use
it to control Kendall.
“Keep clean this weekend, eh killer.”
It’s actually this nice,
moral person in Kendall,
who wants to be a “good son”
and do the right thing,
who gets in his way whenever
he’s about to kill his father.
“Is this, like, objectively horrible?”
“You might never get another shot…
Strength. You’re a good son.”
It’s right after this line
that Kendall self-sabotages
over the vote of no confidence,
making the call to Ilona’s family
which Frank warns him
will stir things up--
because on some level he
wants to mess up his plan
so he’ll still be a “good son.”
When Logan reassures his son that
the boy Kendall killed “doesn’t matter”
he uses a key phrase that
we’ve heard pop up in the
investigation of the cruises scandal.
“NRPI. No real person involved.”
Logan’s casual use of the phrase is
important because it confirms that,
if we had any doubts, Waystar Royco’s
toxic culture really does totally
stem from him.
As Senator Gil Eavis puts it,
“Emerson said, ‘Every institution
is the shadow of a single man.’
At Waystar, that man is Logan Roy,
isn't he?”
not to mention that--as Kendall notes--
Logan is clearly aware of everything
that goes on:
“My father keeps a watchful eye…
and the notion he would allow millions
of dollars to be paid without his
explicit approval is utterly fanciful.”
So Logan is the head that
needs to be cut off.
This is why the first thing Kendall
says about his dad in the press
conference is that Logan
is a “malignant presence.”
“The truth is that my father
is a malignant presence,
a bully and a liar.”
In other words, the energy of his very
being and the behavior he’s trained
others to view as normal create
an “evil” company culture
from which all
transgressions originate.
Waystar Royco’s toxic culture is
encapsulated in this phrase “NRPI”:
this idea that some people (even
most people) don’t matter:
“NRPI.”
“No Real Person Involved"
"Uh-huh and what does that mean?"
"That means it's a sex worker or
a migrant worker at a foreign port."
The series underlines that the way
this abusive power structure functions
(in both Waystar and within the family)
is by encouraging each individual to
pass down the pain they get from their
higher-ups onto those beneath them.
“You pour the shit I’m pouring
on you on your f[BLEEP]ing minions
and you ride them.”
“You know what? Put the
f[BLEEP]ing snacks away!”
This cultural expectation that
you take the shit you get out
on the people below you is
shown most clearly through Greg,
the newcomer and distant relative who’s
the lowest on the family totem pole,
and so is used as a
punching bag by everyone--
sometimes quite literally.
“Ow! Dude!”
“I might punch-bag you
a little, is that cool?”
Mostly, Greg is there
to take shit from Tom.
“The thing about me is I’m
a terrible terrible prick.
I got you again!
I just got you!”
who--as Shiv’s partner and a
relative “nobody” in the Roys’ view
--is that one level up from Greg
and needs someone who’s less important
but still in the “family” to
let out his negative feelings on.
“Just thought family would be safest,
and Greg's expendable. You know.”
“What, you-you'd kill Greg?”
“No. But you know, he's family,
right? So we shut him up.”
As a born Roy, Roman is a
level up from Tom, but he’s also
the baby of the family who’s known
as a screw-up, so still low
on the family ladder--thus we
see him mistreat both Tom and Greg.
“Dude, come on come on, stop.”
“They don’t have paper towels,
they got all green and shit.”
“Dude, seriously!”
Shiv actually takes out
her bullying instincts on
her fiance slash husband Tom.
“I mean the wedding might be
in England but it might not.”
“Okay okay sorry sorry.”
And because Tom can’t honestly
voice or address his powerlessness
in his relationship with Shiv,
he literally beats Greg up
when Greg tries to be honest
about seeing Shiv cheating.
“Shut the f[BLEEP] up, Greg.”
“I’m trying to help you.”
“Shut up. I told you to
f[BLEEP]ing shut up.”
He also violently throws water
bottles at the kid when Greg
tries to get out of working at the Fox
News-like ATN by uttering the sentence
“It-it could be like, like a
business open relationship.”
which strikes a nerve because
it echoes the open relationship
Tom doesn’t want with his wife.
All this bullying underlines
how power imbalances corrupt
any relationship.
And of course, this culture
of exploiting and punishing
the weaknesses of the people you
supposedly love and are family with,
originates with Logan himself.
When Greg tells Logan
“I don’t want to mention any
names because I *stammers*
but the culture there, it borders
on the personally abusive at times.”
“Tom?”
Logan actually laughs and
seems almost to approve--
to be proud or impressed by
Tom’s surprising cruelty.
“I didn’t know he had it in him.”
just as Tom, too, is proud
when Greg shows he’s learning
“slime ball” killer-instinct tactics.
“Are you asking if
you can blackmail me?”
*laughs*
“You’re a f[BLEEP]ing slime ball!”
What Logan relishes most of all
is something that he and the
family vaguely refer to,
in a variety of contexts,
as “the game”
“It’s all part of the game.”
“Oh it’s all part of the game!
“Come on everybody. It’s a rootin
tootin super f[BLEEP]ing fun game
for all the family,
step right up!”
In the first episode, we’re introduced
to this through a literal ballgame
Logan is itching to play
“I think it’s time to play the game…”
but even the baseball game
isn’t really about that game--
it’s an opportunity for him to
work each of his children in
business negotiations around
changing the family trust.
“Okay let’s play ball.”
likewise, we’ll see in later episodes,
often the play is blinding others to
where the real game is and which
big moves are happening outside of
the apparent game.
But strikingly, all
of the constant “games”
we witness the Roy circle playing
“Is there an angle here?”
“I’m not the f[BLEEP]ing angle.”
are not fun at all.
“Tom! sit on the floor. It's fun.”
“Seriously?”
“Yeah it’s a game. Boar on the floor.”
“Why am I in this?”
“How the f[BLEEP] would I know Greg,
you think I have a rational
explanation for this?”
--they’re based on humiliation…
on someone being the winner who
inflicts cruelty and
public shame on a loser
“The rules are that you’re
spared if you tell the truth--”
“There are rules?
Do you know something Greg?
There are no f[BLEEP]ing rules.”
And all this circles back
again to that NRPI acronym,
which expresses that human beings
matter only insofar as they are
reflections of wealth and power.
“Mia’s a real person, with a face.”
“The game” really stands in for
capitalism and corporate power
in today’s world--
and what Succession is underlining,
is that this “game” is
based on a refusal to value
the humanity of people.
Because it’s only by blinding oneself
to the fact that talking about,
for example, waving
“skulls” to shareholders,
means actual people
losing their livelihoods.
“In terms of skulls, how
many skulls do you think?”
“That we can lose?”
“Yeah.”
“I don’t know. Like, I
guess like thirty? Or fifty?”
“Fifty skulls?”
and ignoring the fact that this game
is no good and no fun for any of us;
it actually makes even those
at the top pretty miserable.
“He’s pretty lonely,
and-and afraid I guess.”
Logan passes down his hurt,
especially onto his
primary son Kendall.
During his visit back to
the UK to be honored in
his hometown of Dundee, Scotland,
Logan’s trying to push away
difficult feelings
about his own aging.
And after Kendall makes the
mistake of being honest about Rhea,
“It's just maybe not a good look.
The old f-not-not the old fool…”
“That's how she could make you seem…”
Just-Just being honest.”
Logan responds by inflicting a
kind of emotional torture on his son
by forcing Kendall to visit
the family of the boy he killed.
“Will you come with me?”
“As in?”
“Down to the boy’s family.”
We also see the way this
“pass-down-the-pain” culture
extends to how Logan’s children treat
common people outside their circle.
In the first episode, Roman thinks
it’s funny to play with a young kid’s
hopes and dreams by offering
him a million bucks if he
can hit a home run.
“Rom, don’t be an asshole.”
“It’s a game, jeez,
stop being so serious.”
passing on the public humiliation
he’s experienced so often due to his
father and brother’s “games.”
“You were so damn close,
oh that is so sad!”
“So take this back to your life.”
This kind of behavior is taken to
an extreme in the Season One finale,
during which the central Roy children
callously destroy other people:
in addition to Kendall killing
someone, Roman pushes up a launch
that’s not ready, causing an explosion,
and Shiv hurts her groom by revealing
her affair and “adult”
view of their relationship.
“You know because I thought
we were both grown-ups
and we had an agreement.”
“Did we?”
None of them cause hurt intentionally,
but through a thoughtlessness
that stems from how they’ve
been taught to see themselves
as the only “real” people,
at the center of the universe,
different and better
than everyone else…
and blind to the need to act
responsibly toward other humans.
A third key moment in the
Season Two Finale father-son scene
is when Logan justifies his choice
to “kill” Kendal by citing
the Incas’ rationale for
sacrificing children:
“What could you possibly
kill that you love so much
it would make the sun rise again?”
This is exactly the kind of
supernatural trick Logan is
reaching for--making the sun
rise again for himself,
i.e., giving himself more life.
Succession has a lot
of Oedipus references.
“You & Kendall are thinking
of killing your dad?
That’s a little Greek tragedy.”
“Yeah, Oedipus.”
“Well--”
--a lot.
“And you must be Oedipus Roy.”
“You should probably go and
poke your eyes out now.”
--many of which focus on Kendall
wanting to kill his father
and Roman wanting to
f*** his mother
(which we’ll have more time
to get into in another video!)
“I screwed mom for you.”
“You may want to
screw your mother--”
“Did I say that I was
going to f[BLEEP] Marcia? No.
Although I definitely
would cause she’s hot but that’s--
You know. That’s like phase two.”
But in addition to
the Oedipal idea that
the child must destroy the parent,
the father-son finale scene underlines
that Logan is a “dark father,”
in the vein of Darth Vadar or
Greek mythology’s Kronos--
the figure who would
steal life from his own child.
Succession evokes Shakespeare’s
King Lear through its premise
(and its star Brian Cox, who says
that he’s played Lear over “150 times”)
but it’s kind of an inverse Lear.
While that play deals with
Lear’s folly in giving away
his kingdom to his children
before he’s actually dead,
here, as Cox points out, it’s the
opposite: “he’s taking it back”
Over time, it becomes clear
that Logan’s resisting the
succession choice, not just
because he’s keenly aware that
all the candidates are lacking,
but also because he’s resisting
his own death.
“Shoutout to Rhea for planning a
wonderful funeral. I mean memorial.”
“It’s my honor to salute a man who
will one day bury us all, no doubt.”
When Kendall talks Naomi Pierce into
considering the deal for the Roys
to acquire the Pierce
family’s news business,
he sells her on the idea
that money is freedom.
“You can take the money,
then you’re free.”
But for the Roy children,
it’s the opposite:
their father’s money has trapped
them into what’s effectively
a very small existence--where their
whole world is about striving for
their father’s approval
(and by extension, love)
while knowing deep down
they’ll never get it.
“I've managed to get myself
into this situation where
‘What does my dad think?’
is my entire f[BLEEP]ing universe.”
They’re frequently talking
about being “adults”
“We’re both adults.”
“The adults are talking, how about
you go play in the other room?”
because they all feel like little kids
who are constantly worrying about
what their dad thinks.
“Has anyone ever told you that you
talk about your dad, like, a lot?”
As ﻿Dr. Patti Britton told The Cut,
everyone in the show besides Logan,
“lives in a kind of
caricature of themselves,
and a projection of what they believe
their father expects of them.”
“No I don’t want to call my dad,
do you want to call your dad?
Does anyone want
to call their dad?
“Yeah, I’m right in
the middle, Dad.”
The Roys have internalized the
idea from their father that being
rich, powerful, and successful
requires you to be a cruel, heartless,
overall bad person who’s
totally shut off to feelings.
One of the running themes
of the series is the way that
Logan uses rhetoric of caring
about his family when it
suits his business goals.
“We’ve always pushed
that you’re a good dad.”
“Because?”
“Well because you
are a good dad.”
“There is nothing more
important than family.”
“He's joking, right?”
but shows time and again
that his children’s well-being
always comes second
to the company.
“This is a family business.
But the family is fucked.
And it’s hurting the stock.”
Logan has no time for discussing
his or anyone else’s feelings.
“I guess what I want is for you
to tell us how you are feeling.”
“I feel that I need
to check my emails.”
“That’s not a feeling dad.”
and moreover, he views
them as a weakness--
one which he can exploit
in order to get an edge
in business and
manipulate his kids.
When Logan stages a family
therapy session at Connor’s retreat
for a photoshoot and to
revamp the company’s image,
the episode (like the ranch) is
named after a Napoleonic battle;
the therapist ends
up in the hospital,
“He uh smashed his
teeth out on the pool.”
“Oh my god.”
“Freud would have had a field day.”
and the actual sharing of feelings
later that night is an all-out
emotional brawl with the
father bullying the kids.
“You’re marrying a man fathoms
beneath you because you don’t want
to risk being betrayed.”
Kendall’s, Shiv’s and Roman’s
English mother is likewise
pathologically averse to
sharing feelings or
having them shared with her.
“So how are you?”
“Well I might just as well ask you
if you’re going to go into all that.”
This is most poignantly illustrated
when Kendall attempts to tell her
about his emotional struggles
over the death of the boy he killed,
and his mother rejects his
request for a heart-to-heart:
“Are they difficult things? Because…
bit tired for home truths.
it might be better to
do it over an egg.”
then purposely misses breakfast just
to avoid hearing Kendall’s feelings.
“She’s sorry if she
misses our departure,
she’s got quite a lot to do.”
Even her bargaining to
have them come for Christmas
is just another game to
prove to them that their dad
will choose real estate over them.
“He can keep the Summer Palace
if I get the family every Christmas.
Let’s make him choose.”
Each of the first two seasons
has a moment when Logan is
actually physically abusive--
and in both cases the showy reaction
that it’s not okay feels like
a jarring form of
protesting too much,
because (whether or not he’s
been physically abusive much before,
which isn’t clear)
“Did I even make contact? Because
that’s not something I do.”
Logan is constantly emotionally
abusive and bullying.
“Everybody thinks you’re a joke.”
He only gives his kids love and
approval when they’re totally broken
and in need of him.
If they start to appear too happy,
independent or flying high,
“But she’s kind of a
good one for me, Dad.”
he cuts their wings.
So by infantilizing them,
shaming them, keeping them as
helpless dependent children,
he stays as the top dog important guy
--forever--
stealing back time
from his own kids.
“He loves me he-he-he does.
I think it’s just a wrong
kind of love expression.”
“Yeah. He loves the broken you.
That’s what he loves.”
All of the kids have an internal
split between two selves--
a “nice” or “real”
person who feels things,
and a “hot shit,” “exciting bastard”
persona they perform because
they think it’s what will prove to
their dad they’re good at “the game.”
They attempt to succeed
by being dead inside,
but then inevitably their feelings
rise up and get in the way.
The kids are all surprised and
taken off guard whenever
one offers the other
genuine emotion:
“Come here, give me a hug. Come here.”
“A hug?”
They’re also intensely full of shame,
and trying very hard to hide
how desperately they crave
for their dad to acknowledge
that they’re smart and
can do the top job,
when it’s clearly written
on their faces the second
they get a drop of validation.
“Logan, do you realize how much
power you wield in this room?”
“What do you mean?”
“No, he has a lot of
power everywhere.”
As ﻿Dr. Tammy Nelson, sex therapist
and author told the Cut:
“In many ways shame is the
flip side of narcissism…
the show is about… this
incredible narcissism of the father,
and how he has created these
narcissistic extensions of himself.
It creates kids that are
these little balls of shame.”
“You know, my guy says
that if dad had had therapy,
I wouldn’t need so much.”
“My guy’s surprised I
got through it at all.”
“Not sure you did.”
What all the kids need is
to find a way to reconcile
these two sides of themselves--
the narcissist and the ashamed person,
the “hot shit” and
the “nice” person--
to stop believing that strength
and feelings are inherently at odds.
Ironically, as Kendall realizes
at last in the Season Two Finale,
in his case, “killing his father”
is the “right” and moral thing to do.
“And it’s the right thing to do.”
--so in fact, his moral
feelings can be his power.
It’s this journey toward
being a real person--
who feels things as part of being
a mature adult in the world--
that increasingly looks like
the Roys’ way out of the hell
that is living for their father.
“Is there a thing where we like
talk to each other about stuff?”
(mockingly) “We can
talk about our feelings!”
“How am I the mature one here?”
Look out for our next Succession
video where we’ll dive more into
character studies of our
favorite Roy family members.
“This is your fault. This empire
of shit. Time to pay up.”
Thank you Mubi for supporting
the Take and for helping us
bring these videos to you.
If you’re looking for some
edge-of-your-seat suspense this month,
I highly recommend checking out
Mubi’s Claude Chabrol Double Bill.
The French New Wave director’s films
The Third Lover and Landru hooked me
from the jump.
The Third Lover follows a
journalist who becomes obsessed
with another man’s wife,
while Landru is based on the story
of a real French serial killer
who murdered wealthy women
during World War I.
If you’re anything like me,
these days you may be totally
uninspired and stuck when it comes
to figuring out what to watch next.
Subscribing to Mubi
completely fixes that.
Their team of curators handpicks
every film they show, so there’s
always something new to discover.
They seriously love
movies as much as we do,
so their recommendations
are always top notch.
As a special gift to our viewers,
Mubi is offering thirty days free,
so click the link in the description
below to start streaming now.